okay let's do a little bit more coverage
of yesterday's second day of the January
6th committee hearings another major and
obvious scam that we all knew about
except of course for the millions of
trumpists who donated to it is that this
so-called Trump official election
defense fund which was going to fund
recounts and lawsuits and ardits and all
these different things
it was a scam it was a grift it was if
you looked at the fine print obviously
another attempt for Trump to enrich
himself by raising money and then enrich
his friends and family by hiring friends
and family and paying them out of those
donated funds well it's another thing we
suspected which the January 6 committee
has now apparently confirmed to be true
we have a video from yesterday's hearing
where a congresswoman Zoe Lofgren
explains that the Trump official
election defense fund didn't actually
exist it was yet another Trump grift and
again a grift which victimizes his
supporters progressives were not
donating to Trump's election defense
fund it is a grift of his own supporters
I'm senior investigative counsel with
the house select committee to
investigate the January 6 attack on the
United States capital
between election day and January 6th the
Trump campaign sent millions of
fundraising emails to Trump supporters
sometimes as many as 25 a day the emails
claimed the quote left-wing mob was
undermining the election implored
supporters to quote step up to protect
the Integrity of the election and
encourage them to quote fight back
but as the select committee has
demonstrated the Trump campaign knew
these claims of voter fraud were false
yet they continued to barrage small
dollar donors of emails encouraging them
to donate to something called the
official election defense fund
the select committee discovered no such
fund existed I don't believe there is
a defer to say the election defects fund
was another as I think we've called it a
marketing tactic yes and tell us about
these funds marketing tactics uh just
the topic matter
where money could potentially go to be
how money could potentially be used
the claims that the election was stolen
were so successful president Trump and
his allies raised 250 million dollars
250 million dollars remember when I
brought the story of the Griff to you
only about 70 million had been raised
and then okay we figured out it's
another grift I wasn't going to keep
updating you about the amount of money
by the time it was all said and done 250
million dollars had been raised and it's
a grift all the way down as an example
of how the grift was even further used
for enriching Trump's friends and family
Kimberly Guilfoyle the then girlfriend
maybe now fiance or wife I don't know of
Don Jr she spoke for two and a half
minutes at the rally on January 6th she
was reportedly paid 60 grand for that
speech and that is the money that came
from the so-called election defense fund
which it's sort of like if I were to say
if I were to say hey please donate to
the Democracy defense fund at the David
packman show
if if you're just making a donation to
The David packman show just because I
call it something doesn't mean it exists
and it doesn't mean it's being used for
that like it just gets mixed in with the
money that comes in for memberships and
whatever else just because you put on an
email official election defense fund
doesn't mean it's a real thing and this
was so obvious that it was going on
that the sad part is It's News to people
and many of the small donors who got
grifted and scammed are never going to
know it now is it a crime that's a great
question congresswoman Zoe Lofgren was
asked is that a crime and uh she said
it's for someone else to decide we're a
legislative committee and it's clear
that he intentionally misled his donors
asked him to donate to a fund that
didn't exist and used the money raise
for something other than what he said
yep now it's for someone else to decide
whether that's criminal or not that's
not the purview of a legislative
committee yes and Merrick Garland
attorney general said they are certainly
watching the hearings at the justice
department but who knows what the
outcome will be another scam another
grift not a surprise to viewers and
listeners of this show if you're using
traditional toilet paper and paper
towels you're probably cutting down
trees from North American old growth
forests and I've talked about before we
don't want to be doing that also they
come wrapped in single-use plastic
that's also a mess and the solution is
real paper this is a sponsor I feel
great about real paper makes paper
towels and toilet paper from
fast-growing bamboo not from Virgin tree
fibers from forests using bam boo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and I made the
switch to real paper at home I can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code Pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com Pacman the link is down
below